hi it's matthew from details and we just
saw the Burberry show and is incredible
there was a bunch of good tracks by the
waterboys every editor loves the
Burberry show because when we got there
we can't wait to see what the music is
gonna be it was a huge return to
heritage all the suiting was beautiful
super slam great silhouettes there's a
lot of Gray's a lot of the trenches have
this blanket stripe at the bottom that's
like a collegiate stripe which was fun
to see that was a new take on a trench
which I love there are a bunch of great
crop puffer jackets and crop coats which
is a really cool way to add a sporty
element to your wardrobe by pairing it
with a suit these studded accessories
were gorgeous there was a lot of
traditional pieces like a portfolio or a
pair of leather gloves that they had it
studs to there was a really sort of
young twist on a classic piece there was
amazing herringbone hats they were kind
of a fun way to wear a hat it was all
super wearable and a lot of it was great
because you can mix it in with what you
have follow me on Twitter at details mat
and check out details calm for more
shows in Milan and Paris throughout the
week